- Do you want your house back?
- [Protesters] Yeah!
- Take it!
- [Rioter] He's breaking the window.
- [Rioter] Get in.
- [Reporter] A violent mob
attacked the US Capitol
on January 6th and disrupted the vote
to certify the 2020 presidential election
after President Trump
urged them on at a rally.
- [Officer] MPD JOCC to Capitol
Command, just advising you
that the MPD has declared
this a breach of the Capitol
as well as a riot at the Capitol.
- [Reporter] A Capitol
Police officer was killed
and four rioters died in the chaos,
one shot by Capitol Police.
- [Rioters] USA, USA, USA!
- [Reporter] The Wall Street
Journal analyzed hours
of video footage of the pro-Trump mob
as well as emergency responder
scanner audio from the riot
and spoke to security experts
including a former Head
of the Capitol Police, Terrance Gainer,
to better understand how a mob
of thousands overran police
and attacked the nation's Capitol,
- [Officer] Back up!
- [Reporter] Threatening the safety
of the highest ranking officials
in American government.
The Journal found that the Capitol Police
failed both strategically
and operationally
to secure the building.
Capitol Police and DC Metropolitan
Police did not respond
to multiple requests for comment.
In a previous statement,
the Capitol Police said
its officers were heroic given
the situation they faced.
- [Rioter] You traitor!
- [Reporter] Their Union said
the officers lacked backup
and equipment to control the protesters.
(sirens wailing)
It began at a rally
challenging the Presidential
election results.
- And we fight, we fight like hell.
And if you don't fight like hell,
you're not gonna have a country anymore.
- [Reporter] By around 12:20 PM,
hundreds of raucous protesters
were making their way
to the Capitol.
While some headed for the east side,
the majority approached
directly from the west.
At 12:52, the protesters encounter
their first police presence
on the northwest side of the Capitol.
- [Rioters] Let's go!
- [Reporter] We can see only
eight Capitol Police officers,
none are in riot gear.
They're standing behind a
temporary metal barrier.
- [Rioter] We pay your bills.
You back the (beeping) off!
You back off!
- [Reporter] This type of
movable barrier is meant
to signal that an area is off limits,
not to stop a wave of violent protesters.
- [Protesters] USA, USA, USA!
- [Reporter] The protesters
quickly become aggressive
and easily push through the barriers.
It's clear that Capitol
Police were not prepared
for this type of crowd.
- [Protester] Oh, (beeping)!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, hey, hey!
- [Reporter] The small group of officers
are quickly overwhelmed
and need to fall back.
Capitol Police Chief Steven
Sund who has since resigned
said in a previous statement
that officers responded valiantly
when faced with thousands
of individuals involved in
violent riotous actions.
The number of rioters is
growing as they rush the base
of the Capitol building.
Just a few minutes later by 12:57,
we can see Capitol Police scramble
to form a skirmish line
further up the Capitol stairs
to prevent any further advance.
- [Protesters] USA, USA, USA!
- [Reporter] A Capitol Police
Civil Disturbance Unit,
or CDU, arrives to strengthen the line.
These officers are more
heavily equipped with helmets,
body armor and batons.
- We are protesting that this is our home.
- [Reporter] They're also trying to spot
the most threatening
actors and any ringleaders.
- [Protesters] We want Trump!
We want Trump!
- [Reporter] Visible in the sea of rioters
are individuals wearing
military-style gear
with Kevlar vests, some have
potential makeshift weaponry
like this bat and these flags,
and orange-colored tape
and hats that indicate
that groups may be
coordinating their actions.
- [Protesters] We want Trump!
- [Reporter] At 1:10, about 10 minutes
after the CDU arrived,
the violence escalates.
The mob begins to brawl with the officers.
Here, a flag is thrown,
hitting an officer in the head.
Experts we spoke to say
another riot platoon
should have been on the scene by now.
- [Officer] Move back!
- [Officer] Please, move back.
- [Reporter] Instead, we can see only
a DC Metropolitan Police Bike Unit
has arrived as reinforcement.
These units are called
because they can get
into crowded locations quickly
and their helmets, spikes
and other gear offer some protection.
Rushing to reestablish the dividing line,
they deploy pepper spray,
but some of the mob
counter with bear spray,
a sign that they expected a fight.
- [Rioters] Yeah, yeah, yeah!
- [Officer] Multiple officers injured
at the Capitol, west side.
- [Reporter] At 1:35, we
see more Metropolitan Police
on the scene attempting to
aid the Capitol officers
on the fast weakening line.
- [Rioter] I'll kill you!
- [Reporter] No more backup
arrives and the officers endure
over an hour of assault from
the mob, barely holding on.
At 1:41, we hear police
put out a call that is used
to signal that a unit
is being overwhelmed.
- [Officer] Broken arrow.
- [Officer] Med unit on
citywide with a priority.
- [Officer] Yeah, they're
coming over in reference
to the Capitol building, broken arrow.
- [Rioter] Go, go, go!
- [Reporter] By 2:28,
more people are breaking
through the skirmish
line, forcing officers
to chase them down and
further weakening the line.
- [Rioter] Cut the line!
- [Reporter] Then, after
nearly an hour and a half
of hostilities, the last line of defense
between the rioters and
the lawmakers inside
finally breaks apart entirely,
sending the scene into chaos.
An officer is pushed off a
ledge where just below him,
a group of officers are pinned
and assaulted with a fire extinguisher.
More officers fall back.
- [Rioter] USA!
- [Reporter] And once the
skirmish line on the west side
of the Capitol fails, the
mob storms the building.
As the scene spirals further
out of control, the mob beats
a fallen officer on the ground
and drags him down the steps.
An emerging timeline shows
requests and approvals
for more police help happening too late
and too slow at every turn.
- Help!
- [Reporter] Verbal approval to deploy
the DC National Guard
was not given until 3 PM,
about 30 minutes after
rioters breached the Capitol.
- [Rioter] Stop, he can't breathe!
Take his (beeping) mask off,
he can't (beeping) breathe, dude!